hey youtubers is Charlie so Marvel
finally revealed what was up with the
Captain America hail Hydra WTF so this
is gonna be an explainer for that just
careful for spoilers for Captain America
number one and two the new Steve Rogers
title they finally revealed what's going
on with that WTF hail Hydra in tag at
the end of Captain America Steve Rogers
number one so backstory for those that
don't understand what's going on Steve
Rogers has been de-aged by a fragment of
the Cosmic Cube called Kobuk so Kobuk is
part of this bigger plot line called
Pleasant Hill which is like this
artificial prison that Maria Hill
created with shield to trap
supervillains and give them new
identities new memories it's basically a
Pleasantville Stepford Wives situation
for Marvel's supervillains so the
fragment of the Cosmic Cube that they
were using to do this called koubek
gains a certain level of sentience and
things start to go crazy the
supervillains escape and eventually the
older Steve Rogers who had been aged up
a long time ago in the comics gets
de-aged again but because Sam Wilson is
currently wearing the mantle of Captain
America he has the shield he has the
title this new Steve Rogers comic is
called Captain America Steve Rogers
instead of just being called Captain
America so Marvel gave us back a young
Steve Rogers without completely throwing
the Sam Wilson Captain America under the
bus but at the end of the first issue we
learn that Steve Rogers has secretly
been a Hydra sleeper agent this whole
time so everybody went crazy like the
internet went nuts War veterans people
who have been reading Captain America
since like the 1950s we're like how dare
you the people that actually make the
comic like the writer the artist were
getting death threats it got crazy so
everyone's like what's the twist there's
very clearly a twist Marvel is a Disney
owned company there's no way they're
gonna turn Captain America into
something that looks like a Nazi without
having some twist and so I was a little
surprised to find out that they reveal
what the twist is in the second issue
but you can understand how they probably
didn't want to make people wait too long
to find out so just careful for spoilers
for what that is I'm gonna explain
what's going on so here we go
the Red Skull used the Cosmic Cube Kobuk
to implant false memories inside Steve
Rogers head so this has been his plan
the whole time
makes total sense the red skull would
try to do something like this a lot of
people will actually decry it now and as
formulaic like all false memories what
kind of an explanation is that but when
you know there's going to be a twist
because just the premise was just so
ridiculous Steve Rogers Hydra agent
bullcrap I'm gonna call on that
so Steve Rogers is still going to try
and dismantle the rest of Hydra
throughout this series but obviously now
part of it is regaining the true
memories learning that he actually does
have false memories implanted in him
learning how he's gonna deal with that
they actually did a pretty convincing
job with those false memories like his
mother is approached by a Hydra
recruitment agent when he's a little kid
turns out his father was abusive but now
when you go back and read that first
issue and you see those memories that he
had that all seems like because
they're supposedly false but the other
thing that's going on now is that we
have civil war - that's the big macro
arc that's going across all these big
titles so it looks like we're not gonna
see this version of Steve Rogers
crossover with that like at the tie-in
issue for a couple more weeks but he
appeared in the very first Civil War -
issue where they meet the inhuman that
could see the future and at least a
couple notable deaths I'll put a link to
my Civil War videos in the comments just
without spoiling in case you haven't
read that yet but that was published
weeks ago and we meet Steve Rogers who
is young he talks to Tony they have a
really funny exchange that's an easter
egg for the first civil war in the
comics where he's like I'm not gonna
argue with you cap we've been down that
road did not end well for us the first
time so then right after that they
released that Captain America Steve
Rogers hail Hydra moment and everyone's
like hey wait a minute does that mean
that he was Hydra when he was talking to
Tony Stark and partying with the
Avengers here like what the hell is
going on with this timeline so it seems
like this is all going on while civil
war 2 is going on and I think that'll be
a little clearer in a couple more weeks
when we get the tie-in issue the rest of
this big arc Steve Rogers false memories
hail Hydra is a relatively
self-contained story but let me know
what you guys think about the twist you
know Red Skull implanted false memories
and Steve Rogers to make him think that
he was Hydra so just to clarify what
that means is is that in this moment
when he's saying hail Hydra he believes
it because all those memories he doesn't
know they're false so he believes that
he is Hydra even though he is not so of
course he's gonna learn the truth of
things beat the out of the red
and he'll be the Steve Rogers that we
remember so the other big thing about
this isn't so much the twist I mean
that's a big deal to Steve Rogers hail
Hydra explaining how that works
the other big thing has been the way
people have reacted to this story so
there were a lot of people today when
they revealed what the big twist was
that were like Marvel totally
backtracked they saw this public
backlash against Steve Rogers hail Hydra
and they walked it back super fast not
understanding I guess these people
didn't understand that it can take up to
like six months to make a single issue
of a comic book
so this Steve Rogers reveal was planned
months and months ago before we ever saw
that he'll Hydra moment so the actual
people making this comic book title had
planned to make this false memories
reveal months and months ago like making
a comic book is very similar to making
an episode of TV and then it takes about
six months from start to finish before
we actually see it so like they start
writing it and then six months later it
finally lands on our television it's
kind of the same deal with comic books
because they take so long to write then
to illustrate then to print to ship you
get the idea but right now my favorite
ongoing comic book store lies the ones
that I'm following really closely or
civil war two course invincible Iron Man
and then DC's rebirth I started reading
flash rebirth too but that's only an
issue one like that just started so
because a lot of stuff is on break this
summer if you're looking for something
new then check out some of the Civil War
titles check out some of the DC rebirth
titles both of them are really good I'm
not reading every single tie in but some
of them are pretty cool usually it's
better if you just pick a character that
you really like and just read that
character but if there's any specific
comic book videos that you guys want me
to do this summer just let me know in
the comments but I will be doing DC
rebirth Civil War videos for the rest of
the summer so be sure to subscribe to
get that tomorrow I'll be doing a game
of Thrones Q&A for the rest of the
season there'll be some more comic book
stuff going on so plenty of really cool
stuff happening right now
so why you guys wait for me to post that
video you can click here to learn all
about what's going on with DC at
comic-con Marvel hasn't really announced
their comic-con lined up yet but DC has
and you can click here for all my Marvel
Civil War comic book videos thank you so
much for watching everybody let's high
five I'll see you guys tonight
you